foreign
[Music]
Tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist we're doing Cosmic
queries Cosmic queries today and you
know I can't do that without Chuck Nice
Chuck how you doing man hey Neil what's
happening buddy yeah yeah I guess guess
who we have as a as a as a guest today
I'll play along even though I can see
her on the screen right now
who Could That Be who could that be
she's our resident Cosmo chemist yeah
how many people get to say that nobody
gets we get to say that no yeah not even
the people who work at Cosmo get to say
that they're a cosmo chemist that's
Natalie Starkey thanks for coming back
to start oh no problem I love to be here
I want to chat I want to chat Cosmic
chemistry always always oh my gosh
that's your professional expertise and
you know people don't think that the
Universe involves other fields right you
start out as a geologist and of course
there's geology on rocky planet
um and then you want to know what the
chemistry is we got to tap people who've
got these kind of expertise and you're
just that kind of person yeah plugs one
field into another well I never realized
myself you know when I started out I
just liked rocks I liked volcanoes and
then you know slowly start to learn more
and then you realize of course all the
planets are made of rock and so you get
to start doing geology and space and
looking at chemistry in space so yeah it
just and then you get cooler names like
Cosmic chemistry now what what happens
when you encounter a gas giant are you
like foiled again yeah I know that's
your bias Rich Chuck did you hear that
Bryce well planets are made of rock no
that's what maybe that's what made me
say it I heard that I heard it happened
there's no planetaraki I'm like really
really Natalie that's just a bias I do
much prefer the rocky ones oh
we can give Natalie a hall pass on the
bias there that's fine if if all planets
are rocky to a cosmo chemist then I'm
okay with that so so uh Natalie of late
you were with the Royal Society of
chemistry yeah that's in London it's
based in London also in Cambridge just
outside London in Cambridge okay and
you're a writer and science Communicator
with them
um you've written two of my favorite
books that are out there fire and ice
the volcanoes of the solar system we did
a whole show on that yes we did we
talked about ice volcanoes oh my gosh
that was fun
and uh a book a few years before that
back in 2018
catching Stardust yeah comets asteroids
and the births of the solar system
that's why we have you on now because
the space mission osiris-rex
is bringing back samples
from an asteroid yeah and so was it a
comment which so we we want to first
people have asked questions about this
but but I'm not going to go to until I'm
done with you okay okay
I'm not done with you on this so
osiris-rex that's an acronym so what do
you remember what it stands for oh it's
like yes uh it's like some maybe Optical
spectral uh regolith Explorer or
something like that there's a really
long name um I I was worried you were
going to test me on that because no one
ever asked that it's it's always oh well
I gotta hear my notes I just found in my
notes you ready it's it's very forced I
might add go ahead Origins spectral
interpretation
resource identification and security
regolith Explorer oh that's ridiculous
that's ridiculous somebody said I want
to name it Osiris get us there that's
that's how that happened
it's not the worst there's been yeah we
we do like to make nice space things
like juice I think was is my favorite
but um yeah the GC means it doesn't even
work but you know we like nice names in
space right you want it still couldn't
be easy but yeah okay so so this uh this
Mission went to the asteroid bennu yeah
bennu and that's a that's an earth
Crossing asteroid if memory serves yeah
there's loads of them yeah
yeah you know there's a possibility that
we might bump into one another one day
just you know
well this is so I see why we're looking
at them because you know there's these
there are a lot of what we call
near-earth asteroids um and they're sort
of in this earth environment space
within within you know this sort of
similar orbits or it could be Earth
Crossing in the future bennu it just
takes about just over a year to go
around the Sun and about every I think
it's every five or six years it comes
fairly close to our planet but for the
next day a hundred years it's not really
thought to be a problem it's uh it's not
gonna hit us but there is the potential
in uh maybe I think they're saying 2182
or something yeah November 2182 yeah uh
there is the possibility that it could
Collide us now obviously don't expect
any of us to be around by then unless
Medical Technology improves dramatically
between now and then well wait wait
Natalie you can't say it that way you
can't say adults might strike Earth in
2180 we're not going to be around so you
have to worry
feeling my grandchildren are going to be
you know kind of a-holes anyway so guess
what guess what they get what they
deserve okay so so Natalie just help us
out here because the headlines say
this same asteroid that we sample
collected is may hit Earth in 2182 and
then I looked at the likelihood of it
hitting Earth and the probabilities
around one in three thousand you know
now listen that doesn't sound
insignificant one in three thousand
those are better odds than you get in
many games and definitely better odds
than the lottery so what level do they
say it may hit versus won't likely hit
is there a boundary between those
there's there's a few little things you
have to unpick here and part of it is
that actually we need to go up and study
these objects to understand exactly what
the Orbit's going to be so at this
moment in time we can give it that
probability that it will hit Earth but
as we get closer to that day we refine
these figures so it may get like higher
possibility that it's going to hit Earth
but it may go down and that is often
what happens one of these things we're
trying to understand is called the York
effect and this is the effect that the
Sun the heat of the sun has on an object
orbiting around the Sun and and it's
quite it's not a new phenomenon but it's
something new that we're kind of
studying in detail understanding how
that's going to affect the orbit so
basically it heats up maybe one side of
the asteroid more than the other and
creates more of a spin and therefore it
can very slightly change the orbit of
that object over time but that
phenomenon is quite hard to predict so
we have to study the object more to
understand how it's going to change in
the future so no dependence I'm sorry
I'm just curious here if the heating is
the same as when they refer to solar
winds or would that be a different
phenomenon and does that have any effect
on it the radiation of the sun itself
not just the heat yeah there's different
effects so yeah there's there's another
well-known effect and it's another
starts with another y so you've got you
definitely have different effects that
happen to the objects in space as they
go around the Sun there's other things
for example as for example of comics
that's the one I've just spoken about
but there's other things like if you
take an object with a lot of water in
water in so there's a lot of ice and
water in comets and asteroids sometimes
and as they go close to the Sun and that
water evaporates off or sublimates away
that also affects the orbit of that
object because obviously it's getting
smaller and it's it's shedding material
all the time so these are active
environments these rocks are not just
sitting in space just sitting there as a
rock they're changing as every time they
orbit the Sun and that's something
that's one of the reasons we go to study
them in space because if we go up close
to them we can see exactly what they're
doing we see what they're made of what
shape they are and and what is sitting
on their surface that's going to affect
all of these things and and then we can
kind of refine our thoughts about
whether they're going to collide with us
in the future it's kind of like
predicting a storm in a media like a
meteorologist like you know eight or 12
days out who knows what the path of the
storm is but then as we get closer we
know okay once again Florida you're
doomed
so so so what we what we're saying here
then is if you didn't have all these
extra effects we would know the orbit
precisely yeah right and then we we it
would either hit us or not hit us it
wouldn't be a chance of either it would
just be a binary kind of yeah we
probably know exactly where it was going
to hit but you know this is a 500 meter
wide object so in terms of things that
you can get in space speak American
Natalie
um
I have no idea price 500 meters I'm like
okay how many football fields is that
okay I don't know football failed I do
swimming pools so let's take an olympic
size swimming pool you know it takes me
a while to get down on emphasize
swimming pool they're about 50 meters so
it's it's 10 of these end to end okay so
don't ask about football fields don't
have a clue it's it's a really big
object but in terms of space that's
quite small obviously compared to a
planet
um so if this were to collide with our
planet and if it were to make it all the
way to the surface without breaking up
on the way into through you know
atmospheric entry if it made it as a
block to the surface it would probably
create about a six mile wide crater or
more um and so we're talking about kind
of localized damage it's not going to be
like Earth shattering Earth changing you
know the whole globe is not going to
change extinction level
rights after it hits uh Morgan Freeman
won't have to come out and comfort us
all right yeah he could do that you
never know I'd still want him to do that
um yes but another issue of course if it
hits the ocean then you could have
tsunamis that would totally terrify
coastlines probably doing more damage
than it would just hit land is my guess
yeah yeah I mean would you agree yeah I
think it would be really hot I mean
obviously if it hit somewhere in you
know somewhere very remote that's going
to have less of a fact than if it hits
New York City which is usually what they
use in the movies isn't it it's always
New York right of course right right so
okay so now now now Natalie before we
continue this podcast I want you to
promise me that
NASA going to bennu to bring back
samples didn't affect its orbits such
that it's now going to hit Earth wow oh
man that'd be bad wouldn't it
we go to an asteroid wow and then all of
a sudden we have headlines the asteroid
might hit Earth so now you're gonna
promise me NASA had nothing to do with
that let's let's not make that link
let's not let's expose them uh no but
you know what that it's funny to say
that because that is actually a way that
we could think about redirecting these
objects and there was a mission called
Dart which is the double asteroid
redirection test that that acronym works
I like that one yeah and they did this
just a couple years ago they they
basically put an impact a kinetic impact
into the side of a very small asteroid
called didymus and they changed its
orbit very slightly so we've proven on
NASA have proven and Lisa working on
this project that you can move an
asteroid if you want to if you've got
enough time you can change its orbit so
actually you can do that well just to be
just to clarify we changed its orbit
around sound it's
it's host asteroids the binary asteroid
baby asteroid exactly because it's it's
harder because that orbit is very well
determined right you can time that it's
just an orbit around and asked an
asteroid moonlit orbiting an asteroid
yeah so
um so that made for a very uh
reliable
scenario to test what what effect you
had yeah exactly and we weren't
endangering anybody if it went kind of a
little bit wrong
um because you don't want things to go a
little bit wrong and then redirect
something into an earth Crossing orbit
but you know we've tested that
technology and that is what we could use
in the future but one of the things
you've got to also remember is that all
of these objects are completely
different to each other so um bennu for
example is what's known as a rubble pile
asteroid so it's not like a big lump of
just Solid Rock it's actually made up of
lots of little and bigger pieces maybe
Boulders up to 10 meters in size and
again a fifth of a football field
um and and smaller pieces they're all
kind of held together but it's not it's
not like a solid solid piece of rock so
if you were to push a kinetic impact or
into the side to try and nudge it out
the way onto a different orbit it might
be that it broke up instead of you know
just just moved slightly which might be
worse you then have more people so these
experiments are very important to
establish very important to understand
what Integrity of the object now if it's
so loosely held together I mean that
would affect the way that it breaks up
when it hits the Earth's atmosphere as
well too oh yeah yeah so yeah this
there's so many sort of I don't want to
call the Mondays because they're they're
knowns but
um we don't know exactly how it would
react and if you know Parts within the
internal parts of it are held together
better with that maintain itself or you
know if it's a flying off and as it
comes in it's very hard to know um and
literally every asteroid is different so
you know we have a lot of unknowns that
we're just like okay we just have to
wait and see Natalie I'm old enough to
remember when this was first discovered
where people the the first measurements
of the density of some asteroids and
these are rocky asteroids and they
measure the density and the density was
less than the density of rocks yeah
so how can you have a rocky ask a rock
asteroid where its density is less than
that of rock and people say wait maybe
it's a collection of rocks and there's
like and there's yeah pockets of
whatever it's not rock but the overall
density is less and then we just call
them Rubble piles I think yeah so and
you've got you know you've got other
components in there too you've got
different types of ices not just water
ice you've got other um elements of ice
and you've got yeah you've got pool
space in there
um so they're they're incredibly
complicated objects and there's a whole
you know you've got extreme end members
of all ice and all rock and then
everything in between
um so yeah this is why we need to study
them in space to get up close you can't
get this information really with a
telescope you've got to be in orbit
around these objects um with you know
Advanced cameras to have a look at the
surface in detail
so uh this sample it is arriving now
yeah and so what it'll be a while before
we uh get to analyze it we those who who
of course it's their mission
um what do you expect to find yeah so
Geo you're a geochemist so why don't you
just be ordinary geochemical things that
you'd expect yeah I guess the thing is
we're not going to expect to find
anything I'm going to say alien there's
nothing alien in it we know kind of what
we expect to find but there will be
interesting things that we will be able
to confirm along the way so they
expected to collect they wanted to
collect about 60 grams of rock um I
think that's two ounces maybe
very quick um
but they actually think they've
collected quite a bit more now until
they open that canister
um which lands in the Utah desert and
they're going to collect it and and take
it back to the Johnson Space Center
um until they open that kind of so they
don't know exactly how much they got
they think they might have up to a
kilogram of rock in there which is
absolutely phenomenal that's so much
Rock um and actually the kind of work
that I used to do was on these kind of
rocks and I was always working on
literally tiny tiny pieces of dust and
the amount of detail we can get out of
that piece of dust of a comet or an
asteroid is is phenomenal so the fact
they've got a kilogram potentially is
going to be absolutely amazing for the
sample analysis Community wait wait wait
so how is it that they were after two
ounces it might have gotten
and then you always achieve you know
it's better to overachieve I think the
problem was um they didn't know
necessarily what the surface was going
to look like till they got there and and
this is always the same with these
missions it was the same with the
Rosetta mission that went to commitment
67p and they didn't know what to expect
until they got there and then they've
got to land on this thing well sorry
strikes didn't land exactly it did what
we call a touch and go so it kind of uh
dropped down to the surface and it has
this uh instrument called the tag Sam
which was collecting The Rock and it
blew nitrogen to the surface and and
that kind of blew up rock into the
capsule and so they just didn't know how
much they were going to get because that
depended if they were landing on a piece
of solid rock or Dusty material or what
it might be obviously when they they
mapped the object first so they did all
this amazing you know that the whole
object was mapped and the camera's got
an image of every single part of it when
they saw a big 10 meter Boulder they
were like well we're not going to land
there because we're not going to be able
to pick up a 10 meter Boulder we need to
land somewhere where it looks a bit
finer grained and we can pick up
materials so that had to be very
carefully mapped out before they did
that sample analysis but yeah hopefully
they've got quite a bit in there okay so
so Natalie you were previously involved
in Sample return missions but just not
this one which ones were you involved in
yeah so I've been really lucky to work
on um initially the Stardust Mission
which was the first song for return
Mission from a comet or asteroid
um and it went to an asteroid and uh oh
sorry it went to a comment on what am I
talking about
um and and this wasn't landing on the
comet what they did was flew through the
tail of the Comet so this comment was
just going around the Sun materials
flying off the back the whole time and
they had what they call a tennis racket
style collector that kind of popped up
off the off the spacecraft and the
particle just flew into that and they
collected them at high speed as high
speed impacts and they brought that
capsule back um and then didn't that use
Aero gel it did yeah so I love that
stuff we had a lot of aragel in the lab
I have a little sample of it here it's
amazing stuff it's really and because it
is so light I keep airgel on my desk the
really cool thing about it is that it it
decelerates the particles so they were
coming in at the speed of a speeding
bullet I think six kilometers per second
or something so you need to be able to
decelerate those particles without
destroying them because obviously if you
decelerate something very quickly it's
going to heat up and therefore you've
got all this really exciting carbon
material in these Comet particles and
you know bits and Bobs of whatever's in
there you don't want to destroy that by
heating it all up and volatilizing
everything so that error gel was amazing
at kind of slowing things down and
collecting and keeping those particles
it's quite then hard to get the
particles out of the airgel so that was
part of the sample analysis it took a
long time to process um The Collector
but um yeah so I got to work on those
you could have used cotton candy just
let you guys yeah
it might have worked you never know just
a bit sticky and then all you would have
to do was wet it and you would have had
everything everything written right
there and so before we go to questions I
just let me just give a shout out
to my people here who will launch a
mission
from Earth
a moving platform
do a touch and go on an asteroid
itself a moving platform return to Earth
and have it land in the Utah desert yeah
okay we and know this
and you have people walking them I must
say I don't trust science I don't look
in did diet
excuse me do you see what we're
accomplishing here and it's not finished
that that mission's continuing now
actually it's going to go so it is the
it's dropped off the sample capsule so
it comes back to Earth and now the
spacecraft continues on to another
asteroid so it's going to cost a bit
more money but because it's still
working and all the instruments are
working it's going to go to a pophist I
think it's called Apostles
and yeah and so we're going to study
that and get some more we're not going
to get any samples because that's done
now but we can study it with all the
other scientific instrumentation and see
what it looks like so yeah that's really
exciting all right do you expect to find
Organics at all yeah definitely so bennu
is um it's a sea type asteroid which so
it's carbonaceous so it's got lots of
carbon in it's actually a a b type so
within that it's it's got even more
carbon within it so it's thought to be
what we call a very primitive asteroid
which means that we think it's um it's
left over from the very birth of the
solar system it's got the very first
materials that were formed around the
Sun and these are the kind of objects
where we found amino acids right
precisely yeah yeah so we fully expect
to find amino acids in there um they
should be there they've been found in in
all the other um sample return missions
we've done from comets and asteroids so
far the building blocks are proteins in
the building yeah and I mean the high
abuse the two Mission which um did a
similar thing and came back just a
couple years ago the analysis have been
have been ongoing for that they've even
found one of the nuclear bases of RNA so
we've got so much exciting information
in there
um I think it's uracil is that how it's
pronounced I'm not a biologist but is it
is it a battery I'm sorry
but it's in there so you've got yeah
you've got all the building blocks for
Life Within These objects and that's
part of the reason we want to look at
them what we really want is something to
crawl out of it when we open it up that
would be very cool it would be just it's
trapped in the capsules
okay and now I am older than you I
remember in real I read the book
rare for me to read a book before I see
the movie but I did that for The
Andromeda Strain of Michael Crichton
before he was famous with Jurassic Park
and and whatever his doctor show was on
TV uh The Andromeda Strain was a sample
return from space and it was a bug that
got out of the capsule and and I
it didn't bode well for the town where
the capsule landed well watch out for
Texas then because that's where the
sample's going so well Texas not you
talk uh it's landing in Utah and then
it's going to go to Johnson Space Center
so yeah
okay yeah
all right Chuck give me some questions
for this geochemist here
let's jump to it well we might as well
start with Paul Cinema and thank you
Paul for the phonetic spelling of your
name uh it says hey Natalie Neil Chuck
Paul here from the Netherlands each time
the Apollo Astronauts returned from the
Moon they had to go into isolation
because of the fear of bringing back
something bad for the moon huh look at
that Neil uh when we bring pieces of
asteroid back to Earth do we not run the
same risk and is there any Proto call
yes
um there's protocols both ways because
when we send uh you know earth materials
into space we want to make sure they're
not contaminated with anything from
Earth that's gonna then put it into you
know onto Mars onto the moon or onto an
object in space because we want to check
that we're not you know taking some bugs
there and then saying oh no we found
these bugs on this object look how cool
this is so that's one thing so that's
called planetary so in other words you
don't want anybody sneezing on the
spacecraft before it goes to exactly
Rhino Vibe we thought rhinoviruses on
Mars oh my God and this is one of those
problems when you get meteorites Landing
so meteorites come from these space
objects and land on on our planets and
but they've come through our atmosphere
they've sat on the ground for a while so
there's that you know there's every
expectation that they could have been
contaminated with Earth things but when
you go to an asteroid and collect stuff
directly and put it in a clean capsule
and bring it back and then you take it
back to a lab to open it you know that
anything you find within there in that
clean lab environment and I've worked in
these labs in the Johnson Space Center
they are incredibly clean they're very
hard to get into because you've got to
go through this whole procedure and
you've got to wear masks and a full hood
and suit and everything so you want to
make sure that you're protecting the
sample from you so that you're you know
and it's gone even more extreme when
people have been building space missions
they you know I remember one guy had a
beard he had to shave his beard off
because they just said we can't deal
with your beard it's too dirty we have
to get rid of your beard in other words
you can't go in the clean lab so this is
you know it's this level
yeah
however much washing it's got to be gone
um so yeah that we they sound nasty I
guess you're a slob okay
you're disgusting and there's food in
your beard okay so you're gonna have to
shave that puppy all right but yeah when
we bring stuff back sure
potentially you know we could have
things crawling out of that it's very
unlikely but um we have dedicated labs
for the return missions so there's
nothing else in those labs we're only
dealing with those samples and they go
into special airlocks that's what they
said about Andromeda streams
each level below ground was a different
a higher level of sterilization oh for
you as it went down and you only worked
on it at the lowest level there and they
even burned off your outer skin layer oh
my God has all these microbes you walk
through some UV thing and then just they
wipe the skin off so it's a fascinating
Michael Crichton wrote it the boy has an
MD so he knew what he was doing it was
it was a fun terrifying story The
Andromeda Strain that's cool so I'm
gonna watch that I'm gonna watch that
while your people open this I thought
I'd tell you that okay by the way how
does it land
oh it's got basically is a capsule and
it comes down with parachutes hopefully
oh okay
plonks itself into the desert somewhere
um hopefully in a predictable location
but yeah I mean there are issues
sometimes you know the parachutes don't
open that has happened before with a um
a capsule that came back from collecting
samples of the sun believe it or not
um and it actually crashed and the
capsule got a bit broken but they did
manage to sort of actually collect
samples still that that wasn't pieces of
rock that were collected I remember the
pictures of it that that was not so much
a capsule it looked like a flying saucer
it was like saucer shaped and like it
was an angle into the ground just like a
crash one like like a like an alien ship
yeah exactly I gotta tell you whoever
was in charge of parachutes had to get
fired okay I mean serious it's like
billion dollars we spend and we skipped
we skimped on the parachutes seriously
all right wow so all right so yeah so so
Natalie correct me if I'm wrong NASA
it's the
Department I don't know if there's a
department the division of planetary
protection that's what it's called right
yeah right so it protects both ways yeah
forward contamination and back
contamination exactly yeah yeah you got
it okay okay I Chuck what more you got
hey this is Andy C from Vancouver
British Columbia he says what are some
of the unique challenges working on
asteroids to their minimal or negligible
gravity I assume it's pretty close to
just working in microgravity of space
for most of them or or am I wrong
yeah right completely right I mean uh
Ben is the smallest object or the
smallest asteroid to um have been
investigated in detail
um and as I said it's 500 meters uh
which doesn't sound very small but it is
really really small so how much would
you weigh on Venom see that's what we
were you wouldn't you wouldn't stick to
the surface at all you'd be flying off
so you know if if you wanted to land an
object on bennu you would need to or if
you wanted to stand there you need to be
tethered down
um because you would if you just jumped
you'd fly away and which was an issue
with the Rosetta Mission it when it it
did land on uh the comet and it bounced
initially because you know it didn't
quite go to plan there were a few things
went wrong there was something broken on
the spacecraft and they knew it was
broken there was nothing they could do
at that point attempted Landing but they
then had these tethers that came out and
kind of attached it to the surface and
that was the plan but
um in terms of osiris-rex
um when you go into orbit around these
objects we call it orbit but it's not
really because there's not enough
gravity gravity to be pulling that space
spacecraft towards it so it's really
powered flight around these objects it's
not as easy as going to Mars and just
orbiting around it's it's you're
orbiting but it's not an orbit that is
caused by the object yeah it's powered
flight and it's a lot more complicated
for the mathematicians they've got to
figure out all that um whilst you know
not hitting the surface and not getting
too far away what else are they going to
do wow
just give them a pencil in a pad and get
a little pencil and a napkin
tell them go work this out so okay so
what you're saying is on Earth escape
velocity is like seven miles per second
11 meters per second okay no no 11
kilometers per second right uh so you're
you're saying that on these smaller
asteroids just your if you just trotted
you would be lifting yourself up with
enough speed to possibly escape the
asteroid yeah yeah because that's how
low the escape Velocity is yeah it's a
whole other Dynamic well it's Armageddon
isn't it where Bruce and Bruce and
what's his face go up to the asteroid
and start mining it and stuff um is that
the movie yeah yeah well yeah yeah wait
they don't mind it he's a miner he's a
minor
oil yeah he drills in but they do have
these grappling hooks yeah so they did
give some sensitivity yeah that was
where you know there was a lot of
inaccuracies in that movie but there we
go they they were on yeah
within the first maybe two minutes but
anyway
um but yeah so it's something you would
have to think about if you wanted to go
and mine these objects you've got to
tether yourself on there
um but with osiris-rex it didn't land it
did this touch and go so it wasn't
really a problem it actually used that
that wasn't a problem for it because it
could get away and by the way uh
famously noted in Armageddon that the
asteroid that Bruce Willis had to
destroy was the size of Texas so that
would certainly have a noticeable ground
ah okay yeah that's quite that would be
a lot the line delivered in the film I
know every line in the film and that's
how that where that happened uh by the
way all right all right Armageddon
violates more laws of physics
per minute oh than any other film I had
ever seen until I saw a moonfall
cheering oh my god
oh poor Halle berries you know yeah the
Moon is like turned it is discovered to
be Hollow
a moon creature inside I've not seen
this right
yeah yeah yeah just just get ready strap
yourself in for that one yeah Halle
Berry but I uh bought a summer house and
was like damn it I gotta do a movie
all right so keep going chuck all right
here we go uh this uh next question
greetings to the Royal Court of
cosmology
osiris-rex took a bite out of an
asteroid and I wonder what it tastes
like seriously though is it at all cost
effective to mine an asteroid and how
would it be processed uh should it be
sliced like deli meat ground like
burgers what would the wheat be
separated from the chaff oh my goodness
in Montague New Jersey wants to know
Dave very very poetic Dave I just love
that Dave's being very pleased because
when we separate the wheat from the
chaff what exactly shall we find on the
floor of cosmological Trio yeah exactly
oh that's brilliant oh that question's
got me okay
um yes okay so mining asteroids sure it
it would be profitable if we wanted to
do it
um but there's just loads of economic
implications of doing it so the
asteroids contain tons of precious
metals brilliant we need tons of
pressure Metals for all the technology
we need on Earth particularly you know
car batteries now need tons of precious
metals where the carbon ones don't just
the metallic asteroids right yes but
they they still contain quite a bit of
uh salicious material so they will have
other bits and balls but yeah you'd go
to them
silicate oh
I was gonna say are you talking about
sexy asteroids now well no that Astro
it's very salacious but yeah you'd go to
the right ones and there's plenty of
them up there um and and so when you've
got a metal Rich asteroid um it's gonna
be pretty solid it's going to be harder
to mine than like a rubble pile but
there are ways to do it we have really
have the technology to do it
um the big question is you've invested
all that money you could then
potentially bring all of those Metals
back to Earth and you would literally
flood the market so if you would have a
lot of money but then we would uh
basically wouldn't need any more ever
again
um potentially however that's not such a
bad thing because mining is extremely
deleterious to the ecology and to you
know the the structure of of uh of of
our ecological balances and so to be
able to go someplace and bring it back
space mining I mean you know you're
you're really doing a great deal of good
even though you you would have cornered
the market and kind of collapsed that
sector of the economy other than that
everything
but there's also technologies that we
could develop if we had enough supply of
certain Metals so some things are
constrained at the moment because we
just don't have the supply so we
couldn't say oh let's go make this
amazing thing because we just don't have
that so it could be that we open up new
technologies so so what you're saying is
we would create industry even though
you're destroying one sector of the
economy you're creating a whole brand
new area essentially yeah so the initial
investment is huge um the risks could be
huge huge as well so what if something
goes wrong what if when one of these
companies goes up and starts mining some
it goes wrong they redirect something by
accident ends up colliding with Earth
you know or Mars or something else and
we don't want that to happen and so
there's a lot of Regulation that would
be required but there you know there's
companies working on this there's a lot
of investment happening and I think it
will happen one day but to your point
Natalie the asteroids of Interest would
be the nearest ones which are the Earth
crossers right I mean but as a category
of asteroid those are the easiest ones
to get to so the the thought that a
mistake could direct it towards Earth is
very real but if they're up there
messing with asteroids I might say if
I'm the president I'd say we discovered
an asteroid headed our way could you go
to that one and deflect it you know out
of out of home's way and so they have
the power to get to asteroids and mess
with them they might be our biggest
defense system right because they they
have a dual purpose so let me ask you
when when you identify these asteroids
are there any that have many metals in
in them so like instead of just one
precious like or you know Rare Earth
element uh or rare space element would
there be several is is that possible
yeah completely in fact yeah the ones
that contain metal contain a lot of
different Metals so they'll tend to be
the really metallic ones will be iron
and nickel that on the most part which
is the same as sort of the core of our
planet which is what we think is down
there and that's the reason we think we
know what's down there because we've
looked at these very metallic asteroids
and we think that's the center of of a
big object and by the way I want to
reject iron and nickel are the major
byproducts of supernova explosions
there's a variety of supernova where
iron and nickel it it comes right out
and so there's no shortage of iron and
nickels
and it falls to the middle of things
yeah when you know when they're they're
molten and they form so so we get the
iron nickel for free from exploding
stars and and the other elements as well
but the abundance of iron nickel is huge
in the Universe just from actual
physical Force it's huge so that is the
majority of it but there's tons of it as
Neil said and within that as well
there's all these other like platinum
and all these other Palladium whatever
the metals are there all the heavy
metals that fall into the center of a
planet or the center of an asteroid when
it um when it's a molten blob of of lava
essentially and then um it segregates
into as it cools down into heavy stuff
in the middle and the lighter elements
on the outside so the so there's loads
of stuff in there and even if there's
only like one weight percent of platinum
it's a huge object and that's still tons
and tons and tons of platinum so it's
plenty so yeah you've got everything in
there um there so nature nature
pre-sifted it yeah I was going to say
that the hard work is done yeah yeah
you can get a couple more in we only
have a couple more minutes here what do
you have all right here we go hi Dr
Starkey Dr Tyson Mr Nice Malcolm from
Trinidad and Tobago who holds the rights
to the resources of bennu and any other
celestial bodies the outer space history
of 1967 and the space Act of uh 2015
fall short in providing a clear answer
to this question yeah does anybody get
to go up and just you know is it the
wild west up there you just get up there
plant a flag there's so there's
literally space lawyers now which I
thought was just the coolest thing ever
I was like okay so they're working on
these problems
um and there's many of them you know
we've got private companies getting
involved in space exploration you've got
private companies taking tourists up
into space you've got when they get
there who owns what they get and exactly
who can bring it back to Earth what
happens if something goes wrong all of
this and how do you know space agencies
collaborate with private companies there
is so much in space law to to be figured
out and a lot of it isn't figured out at
the moment the 1967 treaty basically was
saying that you can't use space as a
kind of a weapon you can't it's got to
be anything any work that goes on in
space has to be peaceful
um we've moved past that we're beyond
that now um space is a busy place we're
launching satellites all the time you've
got lots of different people launching
satellites it's a busy place above our
planet now
um and we've we've not kept up so space
law is always it's running and it's
trying to catch up with what's going on
at the moment I believe I believe the
law from a couple of years ago was that
I think Obama maybe signed this through
that American citizens can own the bits
of space they find and I think
Luxembourg has a similar rule I'm not
sure all the other countries are caught
up yet but there's it's slowly this is
like a homesteading kind of rule right
yeah where you if you if you get there
first and you develop it then you get to
it but if you do something with it that
uh I think in the homesteading you had
to make it had to be economically viable
but the idea is that promoted
um uh X not exploitation it promoted
settlements right if so otherwise what's
your motivation to go there if you
didn't have a return on that effort and
the return on that effort is you get the
free land
yeah that was a
yeah it's a big it's a big area at the
moment and um constantly changing field
I can't say I'm up to date completely
with it but I'm just looking forward to
the space wars because you know once we
figure out who's got what you know that
means somebody else got to come along
and be like you know I'm Vladimir
so so one of my more interesting
elements of space law that I read about
was if you meet an alien who's more
intelligent than you and you kill it is
it murder
yes no because murder applies to humans
it's not it's it's beyond murder it's
double murder it's worse than murder you
actually killed something better than
you that's ridiculous that's like a fly
that's like a fly pulling out a AK-47
and blowing he's blowing us away
a bunch of flies pull the trigger on the
gun
it's ridiculous that's terrible
okay Chuck wants to be a lawyer of the
future okay yeah all right keep going I
said two more and we got five minutes
left two more all right all right here
we go let's get back to basis on this
one this is Matt from Perth Australia
hello Dr Tyson Dr Starkey Lord nice how
do you think asteroids are formed given
you need Mass to convert gas to solids
like asteroids how could they form
independently and not part of a planet
or a star can they do that and let me
let me add to that by saying and karami
from raw here Natalie if you add up all
the asteroids in the asteroid belt and
if it's like five percent the mass of
the Moon Yeah so that they don't
actually have
a planet's mass worth of content
what the hell happened there whoa yeah
they're just the kind of the leftover
bits from when the solar system formed
and so you had a star that exploded and
and you've got all this this gas field
around it in a cloud and it condenses
down and then you start to form
materially around it now it's a process
that actually we don't really understand
in a huge amount of detail because we've
never seen it happen we can now look at
other star systems where planets are
forming around them but we're looking at
these you know light years away so do
you think Jupiter messed with the area
so that it couldn't make its own Planet
because it's between Mars and Jupiter
and Jupiter's badass out there yeah so
Jupiter took a lot of them the mass it's
very large because it's made of mostly
gases so it became very large and the
rocky planets became smaller because
they've got all the denser material but
you had all this other material left
over which was the comets and asteroids
they they actually just didn't get
incorporated into a planet but that was
quite good it's useful for us because
they're these sort of time capsules of
that very early process those very early
times in our solar system the first few
million years which sounds like a long
time I understand but we're talking
about 4.5 billion years of History
um they preserve those materials from
that very early stage of star and Planet
formation so that's why we want to
analyze them partly because they can
tell us a bit about how the planets
formed how life got started where life
came from and water so that's part of
the reason we want to look at them
um but yeah they've got a lot to tell us
about those really early stages and and
so another dimension of this is of
course you know when the the KT impact
happened 65 million years ago we think
of that as an impact but Natalie do you
think of that as just oh Earth is just
Gathering more Mass from the bits and
pieces I mean I also see it as like that
that's something that completely changed
the direction of life on Earth you know
we probably wouldn't be here had that
not happened right right life in as we
know it today might not have ever
developed it wiped out a lot of stuff
but some stuff survived and it creates a
new you know route for life to evolve so
um it is just part of the process it's
part of the process of being a planet in
space
um for sure we're going to be hit by an
asteroid in the future hopefully we're
going to know it's going to happen and
we can do something about it but chances
are we're going to miss one um they're
they're arriving all the time as
meteorites but small pieces as well and
that's our show people thank you
what's killing me is that we're hearing
this from an expert I like you know
let me just tell you so I'm glad your
doctor Natalie Starkey Cosmo chemist
instead of Dr Natalie Starkey heart
surgeon listen your heart is crap you're
going to die okay that's that's it
that's it it's all over no it's not that
you said it just you said it so casually
it's so casually
ass is like wait we're on this planet
for maybe 100 years at best and you know
it's been here so long and all these
things have happened to this planet and
we're just this planet in space there's
all these other planets and you know I
do get a bit of an existential crisis
because I'm like we're really not that
important here you know we think we are
but actually we're not really are we
it's it's been here for ages I I don't I
don't think that means we shouldn't
protect our planet and we shouldn't do
things about climate change because
there's still generations to come but we
are going to have to deal with these
things in the future and
okay here we go here we go
um
hello Dr Starkey can you please tell me
are we all going to die seriously is
that no I'm joking
yeah we're all gonna die
okay uh this is uh Kevin he says hello
Dr Tyson Lord nice Dr Starkey Kevin from
browning uh White Deer Texas here uh
what can the sample from an asteroid
reveal to us about the information of
the solar system itself can it tell us
anything about the origins of our life
here on Earth yeah Nelly Just because it
has amino acids why would that have to
mean if that can make amino acids then
so could earth right so so they say life
might have come from asteroids but maybe
life could just happen anywhere and it's
just a it's a curiosity but it's not
it's not the stork that brought the the
molecule yeah so it's it's
think and we know that asteroids have
the building blocks for life or many of
them
um but it's about then having the
environment for life to form so it's not
just about having those building blocks
life is pretty unlikely to form on an
asteroid itself because we probably need
water we need some kind of liquid
solvent that um all these chemicals to
move around in and and form life that's
what we think is probably quite
important so the the combination well
just to be clear what you what you're
implying there and I just want to make
it more graphic is an atom or a molecule
can't just get up and walk and find
another molecule to bind with right okay
it needs some medium it is a medium that
can carry it so that it has these
encounters and possibly explore the
chemistry that could result from is that
a fair character exactly so early Earth
was very inhospitable to life it was
very hot it was molten as it cooled down
it then condensed water on its surface
and we still were being impacted by
asteroids from space now these asteroids
were containing these amino acids these
nuclear bases that we see and all this
carbon-rich material so it might be that
that is how life got to Earth and and
then you know the building blocks for
life and then they had this lovely
watery Rich environment where stuff
could start forming we got these very
basic life forms so that's one where the
water please come yeah we probably need
water and that's why when you look
around the solar system there isn't a
huge amount of liquid water sitting
around and we don't we haven't yet found
life anywhere else so that's why we sort
of make that inference that we need we
need water we think for making life okay
all right well that's a good note to end
on I think you get your approval check
on that yeah I like that I I feel
encouraged
no no it's an important thing because I
I love that you can bring ingredients
but now you need you need the right
environment yeah and the Earth might
have been just that I love that well
Natalie it's been Delight uh we don't we
we need to call you more often than we
do no all right uh and you have you have
a unique sort of parameters of expertise
that feed our mission here and so thank
you and let me remind people that
Natalie was the author of one of our
space shows here in New York at the
Hayden planetarium so uh we have a long
relationship
um with This brilliant cosmochemist over
there in the UK come back anytime well
there it is Natalie we love you from
over here across the pond thanks for
helping us out uh
yeah uh Chuck good to have you man
always always a pleasure all right Neil
deGrasse Tyson here signing off for
start talk Cosmic queries as always keep
looking up
foreign
[Music]